[Music]
since no one's watching the real
olympics
we're going to have our own olympics
here this is going to be the woke
olympics my producers have put together
some of the most prominent leftist
slogans
and ideas that have cropped up in recent
years and we're going to determine
which one is the worst that we should
absolutely banish from society
let's begin
[Music]
this olympic bracket begins with my
truth
versus birthing person they're both
outrageous
but i think this one's actually pretty
clear my truth is
worse because my truth
denies the truth it's true that birthing
person is a denial
of women and the fact that men and women
are different excuse me it's ma'am
it is man but my truth is a denial of
objective reality and truth itself so
you got to give that one too
my truth next one microaggression
or white fragility this one i'm going to
have to go with white fragility
because the idea of a microaggression is
pathetic the idea that
we have so few macro aggressions in this
country that we have to worry about our
micro aggressions and just pretend to be
offended all the time and find reasons
to be offended
excuse me where's the oriental food
aisle
but the idea of white fragility is just
a vicious attack
on white people like a specific group of
people on the basis of their race
and uh it's also it's so
offensive because it's just assumed to
be
truth like there's there's no way to
argue against it because if you
in any way object to the concept of
white fragility that is just
evidence of your own white fragility
according to these people you're so
white it just begs the question it just
assumes its own conclusion
so i'm going to go for white fragility
now we've got biological male or female
versus
living wage this one is easy i mean the
concept of a living wage is perfectly
legitimate there are some wages on which
people cannot live
now one of the arguments the left makes
is that we need to
pay you know anybody jobs that are
really intended for teenagers we should
pay them enough to support a family of
four and they're just
simply jobs that are not meant to do
that i have a podcast
so but you know in theory at least of
course there's
such a concept as a living wage whereas
biological male or biological female
those phrases need to be banished from
society
because they imply that there is some
other kind of male you know there's the
biological male there's the spiritual
male there's the psychological
but there isn't there's just men and
women okay that's the way it is i'm a
guy
and it drives drives me crazy because
it's very often conservatives who use
these phrases
because they want they think they're
being very clever and they want to say
well i'm not
i won't call bruce jenner a man because
that's too offensive
but i won't call him a woman because
he's obviously not a woman so i'll call
him a biological male now he's just a
man he's just a dude
okay biological male there we go okay
cultural appropriation
or white privilege i guess we're going
to theoretically white people could have
privilege right now that is not the case
right now
as a matter of law and society white
people are actually specifically
disadvantaged in
university education in hiring and white
people are the only group that you're
permitted to and actually encouraged to
vilify
is certainly not true for any other
racial group um
but theoretically white people could
have privilege right there there have
been plenty of other
social organizations where you know
white people get certain privileges
compared to other groups
whereas cultural appropriation is just
nonsense
because what what's the alternative to
cultural appropriation cultural
appropriation is when you
you know take on some nice aspects of
another culture
but the opposite of that is just
ignoring other cultures but that's
called erasure
so it's another one where anything you
do you're damned if you do and you're
damned if you're done if you don't if
you eat the taco bowl in trump tower
that's cultural appropriation
if you ignore cinco de mayo that's
erasure my name is crupes
and i like tacos and burritos so
cultural appropriations get in that one
climate denier or undocumented immigrant
oh that's a really tough one that's a
really tough one because
climate denier as if anyone denies that
there is a climate but what it suggests
is that if you don't think that the sun
monster is going to kill us all
in nine or ten years whatever aoc says
it is
this week that you are similar to a
holocaust denier that's why they use
that term deniers to
suggest that if you in any way don't
think that we're all going to bake
and the world is going to end within a
decade that you're basically a nazi
whereas undocumented immigrant
is so dishonest i mean when we're
referring to undocumented immigrants i
mean you know that
climate denier is obviously dishonest
too but but undocumented immigrant is
dishonest in a subtler way
because what it's referring to is
illegal aliens
foreign nationals who don't belong in
this country but an undocumented
immigrant maybe they do belong they're
immigrants maybe they just belong in
this country they just need to get some
documents this is
worker to escuerte come on you know it's
like
undocumented american is sometimes the
even crazier term that's used
i'm going to go with actually
undocumented immigrant here it needs to
be banished because climate denier
is so preposterous and it's just not
catching on people actually don't care
about the sun monster
scaries whereas the undocumented
immigrant stuff actually has kind of
worked and it poses
a much graver threat to our political
order than the climate stuff which
hasn't really taken hold yet despite the
best uh
attempts of of lunatics going all the
way back to the 1970s you know
remember paul ehrlich wrote the
population bomb he said within 10 years
there's going to be mass starvation and
that's why we need
compulsory abortion and sterilization
and then 50 years later the world
population doubled and we're all fatter
than ever malnutritions at an all-time
low so
those guys are just a joke basically
whereas the immigration people have
actually done a pretty good job at
affecting their agenda
okay black bodies versus economic
justice this one this is easy economic
justice also
is a perfectly legitimate concept in
theory the way that it's used by the
left
is usually the opposite of its meaning
it refers to injustice where you take
money from people
and you give it to other people for for
not very good reasons
but black bodies is the most defensive
one this has
been promoted by this very overrated
leftist writer tom
heezy coates he's a darling of white
liberals and tony he's he coats who's a
black guy
but he he almost exclusively refers to
black
bodies you are blacks instead of black
people as if black people don't have
souls
right they're just bodies there are
other humans they have souls but
for some reason according to tanya easy
codes black people are just meat puppets
without souls
very offensive stuff and from a
preposterous understanding of human
nature so
boom getting that one next one the one
percent or anti-science
i don't mind the one percent necessary i
mean the way wall street
uh occupy wall street used it was kind
of silly but it just refers to huge
disparities of power
in a society and it is right now we're
living in a proto-oligarchy i mean a
very small handful of people have most
of the money and all of the power
i'm thinking of the big tech
billionaires and the people who
facilitate their reign and government
and the other institutions so that's
sort of fun whereas anti-science
is the alternative i mean that's just
silly it's
anti-knowledge right now science just
refers to knowledge now
you know over the time it's come to
signify this very narrow
materialist sort of understanding of
things uh
and material inquiry but but it's funny
too because now if you say that a baby
is a baby and a man's not a woman you're
called anti-science
so anti-science that's the one we're
going to go with and then we've got
cis gender cisgender refers to men who
know that they're men
and women who know that they're women
and reproductive
rights which refers to
the right not to reproduce the right or
the right you you have already
reproduced when you're pregnant but then
the right to
kill the process of you know the product
of reproduction namely a human baby
i guess my thoughts on abortion are you
know let's just all have a good time
there's a reproductive right i mean that
just refers to killing babies and it's
so
hideous
[Music]
truly ban reproductive rights i think
cisgender is the crazier one obviously
killing babies is a bigger problem
but at least you're referring to
reproduction even if you're talking
about undermining reproduction and doing
the opposite of reproduction
whereas cisgender it's just nonsense i
mean
cis is not a thing because what the
implication of cis is that
it's perfectly normal to be a man who
thinks he's a woman right trans and cis
just whatever it's whatever you are
and the idea that gender is somehow a
legitimate category so all right
cisgender that's the one that's got to
go
okay we've now we've now understood all
of the terms let's see going back to the
top
my truth versus white fragility
so my truth is a generally a denial of
the truth
whereas white fragility is this attack
on
white people but i i do think if if we
had
a greater respect for the truth i mean
you'll remember there was a memo put out
by the smithsonian institution
that said that if you refer to objective
reality or like truth and
and you know uh reasoning that that's
actually a white dog whistle
so i think actually if we recognized
that there is truth and
the truth is not bigoted but it's
actually open to all of us if we use our
faculty as a reason
i think that all this anti-white stuff
would go away so i'm giving that one to
my truth biological male or female
versus
cultural appropriation that's going to
have to go to biological male or female
that's much more offensive to reality
undocumented immigrant versus black
bodies
hmm i think black bodies is more
offensive because it
it's ironic right now there are two
heretical views of human nature that the
left is simultaneously pushing
one is the trans view it's called
gnostic dualism that's the older term
for it it's an old heresy that says your
body has nothing to do with who you
really are so
i look like a man but i'm actually a
woman if i say so it's the bruce jenner
thing
whereas they'll also say that black
people are just bodies that they don't
have a soul
that their but not only do their bodies
have something to do with who they are
but their bodies are entirely who they
are
so there are these two the materialist
and the gnostic view of human nature
and they're contradictory but they both
attack the actual view which is called
hylomorphism which is that your body's
soul and spirit
anyway a long way of saying black bodies
is the more dangerous one
to a political order anti-science or
cisgender
hmm anti-science is worse
cisgender is a nonsense i mean it's just
like a silly nonsense
but anti-science is really nefarious
because
anti-science is presuming
that objective reality like truth
is now can only be known in this very
narrow way now obviously we know there
are plenty of things that are not
susceptible to this modern scientific
method like
loves dreams hopes joys the eternal
moral order in some ways though it's
complicated
these things that are metaphysical or
don't particularly lend themselves to
the
the scientific method so by saying that
you know all of truth is just contained
within modern science
you're just kicking out basically
everything that matters to anybody
so that's that's worse than the stupid
nonsense about gender
all right my truth versus biological
male or female my truth is going to be
much more dangerous
and then black bodies versus
anti-science anti-science is going to be
much more dangerous interesting
how this really you know with all these
kind of crazy words ultimately what
you're coming down to is just
is there truth or is there not truth you
can't handle the truth
and so now the final battle is my truth
versus anti-science
which one do we need to kick out
my truth this is my truth this is your
anti-science
the worst one is anti-science it's worse
than my truth and here's why
they're both a denial of the truth but
my truth what people mean to say is that
we can
maybe know things about the physical
world maybe maybe not but we can never
know anything about
um morality about how we ought to live
about what we're here for about our true
identities we can never know about that
because that's subjective and the only
things we can know for certain are like
the physical world
but that's not true you actually can
know what you're here for you actually
can know things about the medical world
or about the metaphysical world you
actually can know the existence of god
you can you can know the existence of
god with certainty
from the natural world you can know
these things and we've forgotten that
because our philosophy and our theology
are totally atrophied
science is the handmaiden of philosophy
and philosophy is the handmaiden of
theology
so i think ultimately what that derives
from is this
stupid modern narrow
idea of of science capital s trademark
over the e
and so if you can get back to if you can
recover
a serious understanding of what science
is and the
role of physical inquiry compared to the
broader scope of human knowledge
then i think you could solve your other
problems i'm giving it to
especially after this crazy co-video
anti-science
that's it that's the winner it's the
winner of the woke olympics
congratulations that's the stupidest
phrase the greatest danger to our
society
the world
the thing that we've got to kick out
join me next time i hope this was more
entertaining than the real olympics in
fact i'm sure that it was and i bet it's
gonna get better ratings too
see you next time
you